that's where I'm like I'm not going on  dates right now I'm not talking I don't  have somebody that we talk every few  days every day  I have no masculine energy besides like  my family our family friend Jerry  um I have no masculine energy in my in  my in my sphere in my bubble I don't  because I think  I focused on men and just dick in  general for a very long time  and now I'm I'm just gonna get to the  business  um I understand that the window the  percentage it's it's it's changed a lot  from when I was 22. so all I can do is  kind of equip myself financially take  advantage of the opportunities I have  now to set myself up because I can't  rely on  a man and coming someone coming to save  me I can only save myself now